elle est si je vous en prie bonjour
nicolas dupont aignan merci beaucoup
peut-être notre invité politique ce
matin candidat à la présidentielle pour
votre parti est debout la france on est
ensemble pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse quotidienne
régionale représenté par créer seul
bertrand du groupe la dépêche bonjour
christelle en jouant réalmont jour ni
bonjour madame on va parler de votre
programme nicolas dupont aignan mais
d'abord bien sûr l'actualité c'est cette
guerre en ukraine quatorzième jour de
guerre aujourd'hui vous si vous étiez à
l'elysée qu'est ce que vous feriez pour
arrêter c'est bien est-ce que vous
agiriez comme emmanuel macron non
d'abord je rétablirai l'indépendance de
la france car en vérité la france n'a
pas de position officielle elle cherche
à concilier toutes les positions
américaines de l'union européenne et
j'aurais pris exemple où j'aurais fait
ce que le premier ministre israélien a
fait
le premier ministre israélien n'est pas
parti dans cette surenchère de sanctions
le premier ministre israélien est allé à
moscou et est resté un médiateur et je
pense que la france avait la force
d'être un médiateur produit n'est pas
aujourd'hui ma couette à discuter il a
échoué dans l'après négociations pour
une raison très simple il a eu raison de
discuter bien sûr mais comme il n'avait
pas un plan de sortie de crise qu'est-ce
qu'il fallait proposer alors moi j'ai
proposé un plan vous pouvez retrouver
sur mon site internet qui est très
simple compliquée à mettre en oeuvre je
dis pas que c'est facile attention roule
mais pour moi au delà des sanctions
qui nous retombe sur la figure on en
parlera je pense qu'il faut proposer un
vrai statut pour l'ukraine dans le cas
d'une conférence pour la sécurité en
europe neutralité l'ukraine absolue
c'est à dire dire clairement jamais il
n'y aura l'otan en ukraine deuxième
point statut d'autonomie constitutionnel
pour le dombass c'était les accords de
minsk et 2015 et ça n'a jamais été
respecté par l'ukraine donc il ya un
moment il faut aussi remettre les choses
à leur place et puis bien sûr cessez le
feu le retrait des troupes russes et
j'ai même fait en réalité c'est juste
par rapport à l'otan ou neutralité ça va
plus loin son hôte à l'ukraine dans un
état souverain on peut être souverain
est neutre la suisse est neutre et j'ai
souveraine aujourd'hui à d'autres pays
dans le monde qui sont neutres et
souverain il faut arrêter l'engrenage
des va-t-en-guerre qui sont en train de
tuer le continent européen pour la plus
grande joie des chinois et des
américains nicolas du pauvre elle a
réduit les présidents et craignent un
propose de tempérer sa demande
d'adhésion à l'otan et de réfléchir à un
compromis sur le statut des territoires
séparatistes est ce que ça va dans bsg
bien évidemment mais ce qui est rageant
cette affaire c'est d'abord la
souffrance des ukrainiens parce que
l'occident a joué avec eux à jouer avec
eux byron à armer l'union européenne à
amy l'huile sur le feu permanent pendant
des années on a fait croire aux
ukrainiens qu'on allait les aider et on
les laisse tomber donc déjà on a joué
avec eux deuxième point ce conflit
aurait pu être désamorcée ces désaccords
de minsk je la commission des affaires
étrangères à l'assemblée je connais le
dossier avait été respecté l'occident
n'a pas voulu imposer au gouvernement
ukrainien les accords de minsk mais ça
veut dire pour vous les occidentaux et
la russie ont une responsabilité égale
dans ce qui fait l'angle de la russie a
une responsabilité écrasante
parce que je ne met pas sur le même plan
mais je dis simplement que les
va-t-en-guerre de plateaux télé qui ne
prennent pas en compte le contexte
historique qui ne prennent pas en compte
la géographie qui ne prennent pas en
compte la réalité sont en train
d'engager l'europe dans un conflit
régional qui s'exacerbe qui va ruiner le
continent pour un siècle je pense que il
ya un peu de raison qui doit revenir
même si c'est atroce et je comprends le
pignon qui dit mais ces pauses ukrainien
mais on le sait mais on aurait pu
désamorcer est ce que je regrette c'est
que la france n'aurait n'est pas une
attitude gaullienne c'est à dire ou
celle qui avait eu jacques chirac au
moment de l'irak où dominique de
villepin c'est à dire n'est pas dit aux
stocks arrêtons les français vont le
payer très cher c'est une folie ce qu'on
est en train de faire sur le pétrole et
le gaz une folie complet j'en passe il
faut pas faire nation du gaz mais enfin
mais by donne mais enfin by john lui se
frotte les mains l'embargo lui coûte
rien pourquoi ce fret il l'aimé pas ce
qui va vendre son gaz de schiste et tous
les écolos qui qui hurlait contre le
charbon contre le gaz de schiste la
disent plus rien mais enfin parce que
vous savez que le seul avenir de
l'europe jeu désolé de dire ça va
choquer peut-être le seul avenir de
l'europe pour peser dans le monde demain
c'est obligatoirement avec une
coopération avec la russie parce que
sinon l'europe et hémiplégie encore
aujourd'hui on peut encore coiffer
relais avec la russie un outil ne va pas
c'est la russie va rester donc entendre
by donne nous dire faut acheter son gaz
au qatar et le qatar c'est un régime
extraordinaire c1 c'est un régime
magnifique aujourd'hui on peut encore
continuer à discuter avec des guillemets
josué qui va passer l'épaule en me
gillot il faut discuter il faut faire la
paix il faut trouver un statut pour
l'ukraine il faut abréger les
souffrances des ukrainiens il faut
abréger les souffrances des français qui
vont venir parce que de tous et vatan
quai on voit qu'ils vivent pas avec un
smic pour aller travailler avec un plein
d'essence alors qu'est ce qu'on fait
effectivement les sens
qu'est ce que vous feriez qu'est-ce que
contiendrait le plan de résilience de
nicolet global d'abord y aura il y
aurait la paix et je ne mettrai pas le
doigt dans l'engrenage et je
n'entraînerai pas les français dans une
guerre qui n'est pas la leur qui est un
conflit régional qui doit être remis à
sa place mais là aujourd'hui comment
vous
deuxième fois j'ai toujours proposer la
même chose c'est la suppression de la
tva sur l'athéisme pe on est un des
seuls pays au monde qui taxent une taxe
ça c'était avant la crise et je
maintiens ma proposition alors vous
allez me dire c'est pas beaucoup mais ça
ferait quand même à peu près ont choisi
le maire surtout que c'est beaucoup pour
l'état pas beaucoup bruno le maire n'a
jamais fait le plein de sa voiture
depuis 20 ans il ça ferait 10 euros
entre 7 et 10 euros je peux vous dire
que les français c'était 10 euros quatre
plaintes par mois ça fait déjà 50 euros
40 euros c'est déjà pas mal et
deuxièmement il faut absolument arrêter
cette folie ils sont partis dans une
surenchère qui va pénaliser les
européens et qui pousse la russie dans
les bras de la chine et je crois que
vrai quand ils se rendent pas compte
d'un nouveau monde si on n'a que la
chine l'inde l'iran la russie les nos
pays nos alliés pays d'afrique se sont
abstenus l'avez vous remarqué au conseil
de sécurité de l'onu dont obtiennent
entre et oui donc eu il ya un moment il
faut quand même peut-être un moment
regarder à deux fois bien sûr ça
n'excuse pas poutine bien sûr que j'ai
parfois j'ai approuvé bien sûr la
sanction sur les avoirs des rites des
oligarques russes attention je ne suis
pas dans un pour dire une putin bravo
continuez surtout pas mais il faut lui
proposer une porte de sortie et j'ai
même proposé que l'ouest de l'ukraine
soit gelée comme une zone neutre
d'accueil des réfugiés avec l'onu et
parce que les troupes russes se sont non
pas été à l'ouest de kiev il faut
absolument préserver déjà cette partie
pour que les ukrainiens souffrent moins
mais si vous regardez l'union européenne
moi ce qui me surprend et la france
c'est qu'on est que dans un discours de
surenchère et jamais dans un discours
d'après qu'est ce qu'on propose après
vous parliez des réfugiés aujourd'hui le
gouvernement met en place un plan
d'accueil des réfugiés est-ce qu'il a
raison de le faire et ce qu'il faut les
accueillir bien sûr qu'il faut
accueillir quelques réfugiés qui qui qui
sont malheureux mais on va pas déménager
un peuple
donc il ya un élan de générosité
formidable des français et je m'en
félicite
mais tout ça c'est de l'émotion qui est
utile parce qu'il ya de la souffrance
mais faut traiter la cause des
souffrances autre sujet
le gouvernement a annoncé hier un vaste
plan de contrôle
est-ce que c'est suffisant ce qui est
surréaliste c'est que ça devrait être
naturel et puis est ce que on va comme
d'habitude prévenir les ehpad 48 heures
avant parce que un le gouvernement
oui d'accord mais c'est pas ça le
problème vous savez qu'aujourd'hui les
ehpad sont prévenus avant que lee et le
contrôle 24 heures avant donc les
personnels pas qualifié on les met de
côté on nettoie va c'est donc l'état
faillit pas seulement ce gouvernement je
pense depuis longtemps allez c'est la
jungle donc il faut remettre de l'ordre
très bien et puis surtout il faut un
financement de branges écouter le
sénateur avant moi qui avait tout à fait
raison il faut
assurer le financement de la branche qui
a été créé il faut à peu près 10
milliards on est tous d'accord ce qui
correspond à la crds qui au lieu d'être
mis sur la dette du coville devrait être
mis sur la branche dépendance et puis il
faut surtout ce que je propose en mon
projet vous pouvez retrouver parce qu'il
ya quand même une élection
présidentielle donc presque un mois mais
justement votre position c'est contre
vous mais c'est poids appelé l'attention
des français après ce sera trop tard ils
vont se réveiller groggy je pense qu'il
faut augmenter le taux d'encadrement je
propose de l'augmenter de 25 % ce qui
veut dire 80 mille salariés a formé à
payer à contrôler et à motiver
c'est un énorme chantier et puis dernier
point
c'est aussi un de mes de mes obsessions
si je puis dire je veux qu'on me
permette aux personnes âgées de rester à
domicile et pour permettre de rester à
domicile j'ai toujours proposé c'est
passé inaperçu un plan pour l'équipement
des logements car ça coûte beaucoup plus
cher d'aller en ehpad que d'être chez
soi ça coûte trois fois plus cher d'être
à l'hôpital quand on est tombé dans sa
salle de bain
que dalle et on n'est pas donc il ya une
sorte de je voudrais vraiment qu'on ait
un vrai plan dépendance pour permettre
aux français de rester chez eux au
maximum et ça coûtera moins cher à la
collectivité alors venant à la campagne
qui commence emmanuel macron a fait un
premier déplacement apprécié lundi il a
proposé notamment de mettre fin à la
redevance télé est ce que selon vous
c'est une bonne mesure mais
sa majesté est allé voir des français
triés sur le volet cayla qui on avait
donné des questions d' avance
et nous refait le coup de l'art de la
taxe d'habitation alors
on peut dire ça pourquoi pas c'est
complètement anecdotique parce que
emmanuel macron à supprimer par exemple
la taxe d'habitation beaucoup de
français se disant que c'est bien il m'a
supprimé les habitations me vois pas qui
les accable et de csg
notamment les personnes les retraités
qu'il a désindexé les pensions de
retraites qu'il a réduit le pouvoir
d'achat à travers la pl qu'il a augmenté
leurs revenus des plus riches de france
en toute indécence
voilà c'est ce que j'avais sf comment
vous demandez le jeu demande au delà 10
millions d'euros le rétablissement d'un
prélèvement oui
exonérés si les gens investissent leur
fortune en france cent de l'emploi pour
forcer à ce que l'argent des riches
s'investissent en france 11 0 et sf caen
s'est investi en france mais en revanche
quand il ya des fortunes colossales et
qu'au même moment il ya une pauvreté de
masse qui gagne je dis qu'on peut pas
continuer dans ces injustices et je suis
pas un collectivisme loin de là mais il
ya un moment on va trop loin donc voilà
on amuse la galerie avec la redevance on
va parler de ça et puis on parle pas de
l'appauvrissement des classes moyennes
du racket fiscal sur l'essence donc moi
j'ai dit aux français je leur dis mais
je vais le redire toute la campagne vous
avez un magicien là il vous un peu
hypnotisé réveillez vous vous allez en
baver comme jamais si vous le réalisez
et je crois que les français vous savez
que le premier a beaucoup plus beaucoup
plus que ce que brille est en faillite
parce qu'il a mis le pays en faillite
il a mille pays en faillite il fait la
surenchère il a il a géré la crise qu
vite comme un pied contrairement à ce
qu'on dit et il a arrosé d'argent il
fallait quand il fallait pas le faire
mais il fallait le faire mais il fallait
le faire peut-être s'enfermer autant les
choses avec une politique de santé plus
intelligente il l'a fait il fallait le
faire mais ils continuent à le faire on
s'est dit qu'il fallait dans toute la
france avec l'argent des français il
fait campagne mais je peux vous dire ça
va pas durer par exemple l'indemnité sur
le prix du gaz je peux vous dire
l'élection présidentielle passée il va
nous dire c'est plus possible
mais qui peut le croire il a menti tout
son quinquennat et les français vont
croire à nouveau quelqu'un qui les a
trompés moi je le dis vraiment je
demande aux français qui compare les
programmes moi je propose en revanche de
très fortes économies un livre oui ont
pesé 100 milliards d'économies et vous
en avez eu des pétitions pour les
redistribuer aux français ce que vous
écrivez vous employer l'expression de
mauvaise dépense 100 milliards
d'économies sur les mauvaises dépenses
et je vais vous dire il y en a beaucoup
il ya d'abord les 20 milliards j'ai pris
un chiffre modérée des fausses cartes
vitales des millions de fausses cartes
vitales j'ai repris le rapport du sénat
apport de l'assemblée ça va jusqu'à 50
milliards pour prat
1 milliard pour certains j'ai pris 20
parce que j'ai comparé les rapports je
les ai lus premier point deuxième point
vous avez l'union européenne qui nous
coûtent 10 milliards nets c'est énorme
c'est le budget de l'enseignement
supérieur vous avez l'immigration je
veux supprimer toutes les aides sociales
jusqu'à 5 ans d'arriver c'est à dire que
pendant les cinq premières années pas
des aides sociales pour casser l'appel
d'air vous avez été par exemple ne
seraient plus remboursés non les
dépenses hausse et je parle des aides
sociales style rsa allocations logement
etc
de 3e 4e point la grande fraude à la tva
j'ai écrit un rapport parlementaire là
dessus c'est colossal et fraudes et
escroqueries à la tva internationale
taxer les gaffes à
exploitent nos données sans les payer à
vous à moi donc il ya gisements et je
suis le seul candidat qui dit on fait
des économies là dessus et on redéploie
pouvoir d'achat en augmentant les
salaires en baissant les charges
salariales un 13e mois pour tous
indexation des pensions de retraite et
aide aux pme pour s'investir localement
baisse de moitié de l'impôt sur les
sociétés pour réinvestir en france et
dernier point j'ai fini les services
publics c'est à dire l'hôpital on rouvre
vingt mille lits quand emmanuel macron
on a fermé 17000 à moi sur une mesure de
votre programme c'est le référendum
révocatoire on parle des mesures
institutionnelles référendum révocatoire
à mi mandat c'est ce que avec septennat
comment ça marcherait est ce que ça vous
permettra de faire des réformes dures
des français
d'abord au delà du référendum
révocatoire je pense que la démocratie
française est malade et que c'est ça la
cause majeure pour moi il ya 2 cos et
l'union européenne et la démocratie qui
ne fonctionne plus nous sommes plus on
vraiment démocratie nous sommes dans une
ligue archi et je pense qu'il faut le
rique cinq cent mille signatures un
référendum ça existe en suisse est pas
la révolution et les français sont sages
deuxième point l'usagé du référendum par
le président n'a pas été utilisé depuis
2005 et troisième point ce qui existe
aux états unis en californie le
référendum révocatoire retour au
septennat pour avoir du temps mais à mi
mandat s'il ya une certaine un nombre de
populations qui le demandent il ya la
possibilité de renvoyer un président à
faux le déterminer mais un nombre élevé
il s'agit pas de mettre en instabilité
le pays mais il s'agit de dire aux
français
et je veux vraiment insister là dessus
le poison c'est l'abstention les
français ne croient plus qu'on fait donc
est ce que comme le général de gaulle
avait voulu avec la cinquième la
cinquième au début c'était ça c'était la
parole au pop et les parties ont
confisqué la parole c'est même pas des
partis d'ailleurs c'est une oligarchie
des grandes entreprises et des grands
médias qui appartiennent à des
milliardaires etc
oui une question d'une question
politique eric zemmour a été rejoint par
marion maréchal il y à des anciens du
rassemblement national dlr avec comme
guillaume pelletier
il a fait l'union autour de lui est ce
que vous rejoindrez y ait cette union je
suis candidat gaulliste il ya des points
communs bien sûr l'indépendance de la
nation mais il ya des points différents
j'ai pas la même vision de la société
notamment sur la place des femmes
d'ailleurs mais au-delà de ça eric
zemmour est un candidat j'en suis un
autre jeu offre une voie gaulliste et
notamment à points dont on n'a pas parlé
sur la liberté
j'ai été effaré de ce qui s'est passé
pendant le coc vide et je serai le
candidat de ceux qui refusent absolument
le pass sanitaire le pass vaccinale qui
n'est que ce sera de manière mesurée
plein il n'est pas supprimé j'insiste et
je crois que j'ai une vision différente
je veux rendre la liberté aux français
et ça c'est pas négociable donc je vois
que les autres candidats ne le font pas
mais vous n'aimez pas un jour de le
rejoindre mais pourquoi il peut me
rejoindre si nicolas dupont aignan
remercie mes rares et c'est notre invité
[Musique]